good to be here I was just scrolling my
facebook wall backstage looking at what
people post this seems to be a popular
video somebody goes to a wedding now
somebody posts the video of the groom
and the groomsmen doing a choreographed
dance further bride I got married three
years ago I couldn't get my groomsmen to
go get the tuxedo fitting let alone come
to my house there's a men in their 30s
you gotta call your buddies and ask them
to do this how does that phone call even
work
hey Frank listen I'm getting married I'm
thinking midway through the wedding
after reasons that the dessert would
come out to Timberlake is in the Chris
Brown wife
I got two jobs in a family
no people post everything on Facebook
I'd rather tell people here like tonight
I'll tell you guys my wife and I having
a baby my first
[Applause]
but we tell some of our friends like oh
you can take photos and share the photos
of the pregnancy announcement on
Facebook have you seen some of these
announcements the poor guy is on his
hands and knees kissing the valley my
bodies would rip me to shreds if I
posted something like that you asking
for money on Facebook every third post
that's like panhandling the GoFundMe
page was it how about this
go work don't get me wrong I'm all up
for a good fundraiser for a good cause
five-year-old kid don't have a leg let's
buy this kid up to ninety eight year old
father bags why do I gotta pay for the
funeral it's not a fundraiser I call
that poor planning you didn't see this
coming
you bought a Lexus now your father don't
got a casket you guys are great god
bless you
[Applause]
you